hello everybody my name is Ludwig von
Paulin crasher and welcome to let's play
the worst work out of your life okay now
you want to make your country proud yes
yes to get down on the floor stand up
from your desk get on floor and begin to
squats yes you feel burn oh yes
back in my home country we did squats
for days on end
never landing to get my muscles to Macon
country proud
maybe someday go Olympics then win medal
for countries to buy potatoes sorry for
spitting so much does my speech bother
you like a cloud of mist in front of my
eyes tiptoe squats but not to squat stop
until you die or I crush your balls like
little walnuts don't you want to crush
coconuts between your legs
who does it this is not workout just for
men it was more for women as well Bobby
does my sweet bother you with no problem
you keep those squat until you die and
then you keep buns of steel to make good
potatoes and field work for wrong
country and then be great for Lada
Russia it's going to be good ahh diet
don't Scottish now
ah you're never gonna get in till you're
getting squat you gonna do
are you gonna be home country proud and
you're not Scott a Russian Latvian
trying to scrape together squads for
potatoes until you make your own guts
leap round
you
Oh